what's happening there reject nation we're going
to watch today superman and lois hey we do our
full-length watch alongside around lois over at
our patreon page special thanks to all become
superjects if you can't share your support over
there sure to support by leaving a like today
that would mean a lot also subscribe and click
the notification bell to get notified when our
reaction for the next snl is up on the channel
and then prepper boys you're the real super boys
of the real rejects thank you guys so much helping
us edit these down let's swing into action people
until he reveals the location of that thing that
killed our men superman will remain a prisoner
of the united states government usa getting
the job done your arrest was sanctioned by
general hard castle herself and i don't trust
you to keep your word so tell me where he is
ooh cool shot odds at itself
there's a greater threat here
her name is ali alston she's a cult leader
whatever brought your suspect to this world
she knows more about it than anyone
whoever this woman turns out to be
changes nothing you will give me the location of
my suspect or i'm gonna cry you guys are gonna
have to keep yourselves busy after school okay
until your grandfather and i figured this out
sure you deal with jordan's drug problem just the
two of you i mean jonathan i didn't really want
sophie to see well i didn't want you to see well
this is what's got to happen right might as well
just get it over with burn it all none of this
is your fault none of that is yours either okay
i don't know about that take a good hard look at
yourself sarah it's only been one night and it's
just so hard seeing my mom cry all the time
i can imagine i don't really know if you can
oh [ __ ] the raid all the lockers arrest
her ass still thinking about how sexy you
feel i i did have a little help yeah and it
worked so uh yeah i bought you a month's supply
that should last you a while candace don't worry
i'll look you up with a good price no no no
actually i think i'm done don't
are you out of your mind i can't
everyone i need you to step away from your locker
i'm not that that's a joke it's for the xk i can't
get caught with this stuff jonathan but you
can i'll dump it i'll dump it okay you good kid
there's no way they're going to check me
[ __ ] plan i mean after everything you've done
for humanity to find yourself here do you ever
stop talking and did i not bring
you face to face with our mother
for that good deed alone i deserve at least
some credit i think how are you deserved
to be locked up in here i love them together
what would you offer for my cooperation
oh that's messed up
goddammit anderson [ __ ] torture do you
know anything about jonathan kent taking
this drug from the mines whoa no i didn't know
anything about it thank god yeah but please
just promise me not to smoke space drugs yeah
i'm not that stupid oh man that sounds so fun
way better than regular drugs might be good for
you to just vent to a friend a little bit is
there anyone else you feel comfortable
talking to about this john's daughter
do it girl time are you selling drugs no mom i
promise my girlfriend is selling drugs i am so
pissed and trust me jonathan your
father will be too once he's out of jail
maybe you could talk to him on your way to jail
i have had enough disappointment for the day so
get upstairs right now both of you god poor lois
he's at 76.2 north longitude 100.4 west latitude
thank you
i think that mayor dean made a big
mistake bringing up the family values
i'm pretty sure i still have a husband that
cheated on me but you are a great mom and
accusing a good mama being a bad one is terrible
politics especially when you're the kind of the
victim of this situation i just need to call
him out take the fight to him get some dirt yeah
what is that your supplier freaking out well i
wasn't one telling drugstore football team so jeez
i don't know why you're getting all
this trouble if it was someone else's
though look i made a dumb decision
can you please just leave me alone
what's the big deal so your
girlfriend loses her house come
don't threaten me you're not the one being
brought to heal by some barbarous kryptonite
collar perhaps i might extend my leash by
shining a light on all your many lies enough
is it brother i think not oh any idea what
this is it's that thing's suit superman must
have warned him that we were coming they're
working together this whole time superman's
been lying to me and there's the proof no why
what a lot of conclusions you jump to me jeez
prisoners back away from each other now oh my
god use this as a moment to get out back away
or my soldiers will open fire of course my
apologies sir general hart castle's on line
one says he's been trying to reach you says
you're fired check his pulse soldier do not
damn
dang oh look here comes the
cabaret zip out of there
you had it coming anderson you really believe
they've been working together this whole time
how else do you explain what we've seen we have
to presume that everything is part of some plot
good luck giving grass to give a damn i need a
chopper ready to go asap but sir general heart
castle she's gonna take all my command if i
don't prove that i'm right the best way to
do that finish this best motivation prove
that you're right what are you gonna do
simple we uh kill the batman i'm gonna
kill my bad guys i'm bringing superman back
oh my man you above the law
oh [ __ ] everyone's got
super powers who have you escaped
a prison and have joined forces
no other choice it was glorious mother
two sons of krypton vanquishing action
yeah buddy the closest to brothers what drove us
apart greed power your wife tried to kill me oh
[ __ ] geez yeah all the women in clark's life are
married to formidable people in other universes
so i know that i shouldn't have ghosted you
after camp oh oh oh oh i just wanted to say
i'm sorry okay well then apology accepted let's
kiss and make makeup my dad cheated on my mom and
i feel like you're the only person who might
understand childhood divorce to the rescue
he just won't stop calling do you want to talk
to him kind of i mean it it just doesn't seem
fair to my mom but it's not about her it's about
you and if you want to see your dad see your dad
oh it's also later than i thought
so i should probably get going
uh-huh maybe we could be friends again
oh i better pee old boyfriend if i was
i know he was carrying them but you got to
believe me i think he was just trying to cover
for somebody else i hope you're right but you're
still in trouble for knowing about this yeah i
know then what did john do with all that money
could be paying for lana's campaign he can buy
himself his own john henry suit i know i feel like
everybody in this family is great at something
i just i want it to be great i guess and
just so you know i would never sell drugs
i believe you're sweetie i do john you're great
at being normal taking drugs like that is just
something i never even thought you would consider
doing i'll make it up to you do you want some xk
i know where you can get some easy friends and
family discount honey i know that you think
that what you are doing is right but sometimes in
life there are mistakes that we cannot take back
and i assure you this is one of them i'm sorry
you got great kid damn something is coming
it's a missile hello oh [ __ ]
you don't have to do this i'm bringing you in
all of you by any means necessary including
you hologram lady whoa wow what a dick
that can affect him right yeah
won't break the force field
hahaha
oh yes
smash his face smash his face
in you must disintegrate them
not so tough without your inhaler
guys such a dick
no no he's not healing oh time
in prison under the solar lamps
fly and fly him to the highest point
oh man cruel [ __ ]
what whoa no no
this heartbeat sounds backwards
oh no fly bizarro to the moon anderson escaped
but i'll find him what if the other you
he's dead damn tell your son i'm sorry wow well
maybe someday you can tell him yourself ha hate
anderson what kind of person you are someone so
willing to attack a member of this family during
one of the most painful moments of their life
yeah they're loser that way juice news to me wow
can we talk yeah
you and i are gonna have a long
talk about all the important things
i thought you already knew so that you don't
ever misrepresent yourself or this family again
music's backwards yeah that's good
catch he's bizarro in disguise
john dude just rat out your girlfriend he
thought you were dangerous enough that i
should look into you and i have something that he
wants but i think it belongs to you oh [ __ ] you
can you tell me what this is
that is the way to change the worlds
i hate this guy so much he's the worst
she said change the worlds he's the worst yeah
yeah
that was so funny that episode that
was the most i've laughed all show all
year long 2022 most laps wow that was um
that was dramatic that was uh yeah that was
a good tear-jerker episode everyone's going
through some emotional struggles right now
do you just like is there
something you want to talk about
no sure no you sure no i'm fine
i'm fine i can't tell you can't rat
on yourself on my own opinion feels like
there's something in you that needs to come out
and he's so emotional jokes this is banter
jokes that's it this isn't bad there's no
camera right this is just you and i the therapy
sessions no no not therapy i'm an acquaintance
talking with you okay purely mutual friends
that's how we know each other okay so we'll
keep this surface level not too deep nothing
could be uncomfortable but also nothing too plain
yeah i i feel you well jonathan my dude
suffering the repercussions it is conflicting
to a certain extent if i was in his position
i would feel conflicted i would yeah it would
be hard i wouldn't want to rat her out so i
should be like man she's hot she's into me
i can't lose this never happened damn well if
i'm the guy who's known to snitching on his chick
yeah no one's gonna want to date me then it's hard
man well it's her mom i'm glad he's suffering the
consequences of it and that's like painstaking and
there's there's a lot he has to deal with and uh
he's probably gonna get his powers at some point
so it's all gonna be early but yeah they don't
have awakened his latent kryptonians yes yeah
he's gonna he's gonna get something so all right
however um the way how this is all going for him
is really painstakingly awful and i like the way
it's being portrayed you know like you're slowly
watching him crumble as someone who has just been
really closed off not wanting to talk at
all and then by the end you know would
having your brother come at you having your mom
come at you and then your dad who you've been like
worried about who's finally home and his first
words are you're gonna get homeschooled yeah
you're expelled and i'm very disappointed
in you what were you thinking he has to deal
with the weight of that yeah watching it all
crumble on him was that was rough man that's
hard there's a lot of like family struggles
here you know that's what the whole episode
really dealt with family struggles hard times
with the family supes and his brother his name
yeah yeah i'm watching uh how that all progressed
and you see like these little shades that there's
development and true care happening i like that
they didn't do like a full swing yeah you know he
takes a couple of shots for him he then says i'm
sorry to your son he sort of accepts the plight of
the situation that he's in with being brought
back to the red room he's like he knows his
brother so well they're like yeah this lines up
this would have been yeah this is always gonna go
but at least yeah at least i can understand
him a little better and hey maybe someday i
will get to say sorry in person to jordan and
then it's interesting how they've been flipping
a lot of this around like bizarro dying there's
still a chance i feel like there's gotta be i
feel like back in some way yeah and i mean you
know he's been just like locked up the past
couple of episodes there's got to be more for
him to do and more for him to dazzle us with
uh i don't know how he jenna does he has powers
from the sun or would it be something like he gets
it from the moon is that something i think i think
they address it i mean he says on this planet i'm
not as strong because of the sun like the sun here
doesn't give me as much power as the sun at home
uh but yeah i don't remember if there's like a
what the equivalent would be you have like does
he because you know like the moon's light is just
reflected off the sun so i don't know but then
again you know with the mumbo jumbo of sci-fi you
could easily be like whoa special lunar juju that
you know but yeah i i wasn't 100 clear on that but
yeah it's interesting too they they had that be
you know the the ex kryptonite they established
that in the first you know glimpse we get into
the other side that like oh there's a lot
of it over there and it's you know the main
threat to bizarro superman so yeah that that
enhanced the stakes of his fight with anderson
you have this like little hand grenades
basically he's able to blow up on him
yes that was uh that was brutal it was
mean-spirited yeah this means angry character
that anderson props to that guy because uh he he's
he's good at that character because i do hate him
but uh i think the actor does a good job
making that happen in a way that still feels
you know well mixed into the show yeah he's a [ __
] [ __ ] guy [ __ ] [ __ ] man [ __ ] bird i don't
like him at all never did never trusted him the
show wanted you to not trust him from the get-go
freaking sam's not close to being retired no he's
making calls all day i don't understand what it
is he's doing hell it does work ever since he
come back what he does is he he does not have a
retirement going no the only difference is now
he can make calls from like his fishing boat
which he's never on anymore yeah he's just
tending to more of this military family turmoil
but yeah when bizarro died yeah that
is a that's a tough choice you know and
i like the foreshadowing early on about to
give you guys i'm about to give you guys a
visual clue if i was to do a breakdown
of this get ready to be super duper
impressed with what greg's about to tell
you are you ready mind blown in three two
one early on in the episode he is being told you
know bring me your other self bring me bizarro
and it's doing a profile shot cutting back and
forth between superman talking with anderson and
then when it cuts superman on his profile the what
superman's looking at he's seeing a reflection of
himself the reverse of himself and early on he's
being presented with a choice do i save my brother
who's being tortured in the cell with me or do
i save myself and then at the end of the episode
he makes the choice he saves his brother visual
references thematically overshadowing what's
happening there before our eyes oh it's like they
knew it was gonna happen with the beginning of the
episode even though it wasn't done yet mind below
are you not mind blown that's called picking up on
film making visual details i don't know about you
but i'm impressed yeah and then uh lois man lois
and jonathan whenever they're having some type of
coral that's always so emotional so heartfelt man
i like that they do weave through the gray
areas you know like i'm disappointed in you
but i still love you there's a common
rhetoric that john and i have every day
you know i am jonathan in this in in this in this
house is life you are jonathan from this episode
i am jonathan from this every day yeah
not a two-week time span like this show
every day sorry and yeah her performance is so
solid oh yeah i like the way how lana handled that
[ __ ] with the mayor too flipping his actions
on his head this town is the definition of sheep
like jesus christ what happened
in that diner in that diner
lo long gang got [ __ ] going on her ass she don't
know what she do how can we try herbie goddammit
can't keep her husband in line it's a freaking
town and then lana shows up says like two senses
are like oh man i never considered that [ __ ]
that person's circumstances before i realized
how messed up this is that we're in that lot well
and also too i mean like mayor dean's talking and
like half the people who were like giving lana the
business the first time were like his best friends
so i'm like oh you don't really care about
smallville you were just planted there
now anderson's here what's neat is that this this
season the way it was kicking off would seem like
the main villain would be bizarro whoever was in
that misleading doomsday suit that was the kickoff
and then now as we've progressed it's become
ally and anderson working together toe-to-toe
you know and now superman has to somehow take
them on while lois has to save lucy and then
lana and some other girl with an l name sam going
back to the person who she cheated on jordan with
the show's trying to tell us you should be friends
with the person you had an affair with and it's
okay to forgive cheaters in fact you should cheat
just cheat it's better in the long run and if you
can forgive yourself for cheating you will be a
stronger individual absolutely um next episode
is just gonna be a bottle of just kyle yeah i
don't know why she didn't go to natalie uh well
i don't know i mean she's got a different trauma
to deal with in terms of parental figures so yeah
that's all cool though you can't go to the person
you cheated along with yeah but you know you gotta
have that like yeah we grew up together okay
that's fair you got up with aubry yeah she did
they went to camp together yeah but didn't they
just since they say something about before then
and then they just didn't talk since camp
uh you're probably right i don't know why
is she two hours away well you know people
move sometimes when you get older you're not
soon enough i mean i'm not gonna move two hours
away but uh you know seem different uh i don't
know it doesn't matter still cheated should be
excommunicated she should be executed execute kill
george to find her laser heard it down
yes homeland right into the eyes until
there are holes through the back of her head
yeah yeah no forgiveness and no gray areas
or should she talk to a therapist that she should
go to betterhelp.com use our special promo code
betterhelp.com doubletoasted get yourself
some therapy therapy today yeah so this is uh
this is turmotulis turmutulis is the
correct spanish pronunciation turmeric
and so yeah guys i don't know where her house is
all gonna play out there's still enough so much
about ali and what's going on there she'll be a
good guy at the end the season doesn't feel as
is it's different in the way excuse me it's
different in the way they're unveiling everything
because last season was pretty simplified it was
a morgan edge guy that was about it i don't trust
him oh i was right not to trust him oh wow i
mean they had the steel guy show up too yeah
you know those two oh yeah that last one was like
oh yeah okay this guy likes lex luthor actually
now you think about it they're kind of doing
similar beats here yeah guy shows up lex luthor
oh it's not really lex luthor it's somebody else
and maybe it's lex luthor who created the suit
from another unit like that's where a lot of
us went to with that come to find out it's not
it's actually steel and the real big baddie
is someone who's a business person who has
followings and it actually has some supernatural
element here that requires world domination
they've actually just repeated the same videos
different characters in sprinkle a different
kind of family drama on top of that they have some
friction between chrissy and lois and there you go
instead of jordan struggling with being on
the football team it's jonathan struggling
with the football team yeah [ __ ] man this show
has no origins no original ideas or in some ways
it's a deeper understanding of mirroring effects
that reflect reversal bizarro think about it
a lot of what's happening is just happening
in a different mirroring sort of way
you write down to anderson the dod you know
he is conflict with the mirror opposite of sam
there you go see you guys this season's the mirror
season from the first deep depth depth hashtag it
hashtag depth hashtag this the deep end all
right people thanks so much for being here
i think uh i think i have demonstrated how
intelligent i am your intelligence leaves me
in awe i love you but i'm still disappointed
guys let's do a patron of the day shout out
brian perry perry white what connections to the
daily planet dude brian perry i hope you're having
a good march that you're marching into the month
with a super sense of self worth and value on the
up and up righteous out in the sunlight bringing
hope to everyone in your family everybody around
you whether blood related or chosen i hope
that you're bringing light into their day and
anything that might be backwards in their lives
or your life you can handle it man you can set
things right and uh hey we appreciate you being
here you bring us a little extra hope just by
being involved just by showing your support each
month so brian i hope you're doing well that's the
front headline all right who's the best guy brian
perry love you buddy hope your 2022 is going well
and we will see you next month in another
rousing edition of patron of the day shout outs
love you buddy be well i was burying
a body that's what i was doing oh my
we covered for you brian the camera
cut the camera
cut cut cut the camera
you